Transcriber: Hiba Alraisi
المدقّق: sultana idris
♪  موسيقى ♪
من منكم من يلعب ببجي؟
حسنًا، من منكم يتابع قصص الإنستجرام؟
نعم صحيح هو جيل برامج التواصل الإجتماعي
وجيل ببجي
أنا مثلكم من هذه المجموعة
لكن ما فعلته هو أنني تابعت
هذه الأشياء فقط في العطلات
وكان أكثر تركيزي يُصَبُّ على
البرمجيات والذكاء الاصطناعي
كانت بدايتي بسيطة جدًا
فبدأت بالمكعبات والسكراتش
وفي يوم من الأيام
كنا عائدون أنا ووالدي من كربلاء
فشعرت أن عينه بدأت تغفو
وأراد أن ينام أثناء القيادة
وتعلمون أنه لو نام ستحصل
حوادث خطيرة ومميتة
فأصبحت أفكر طوال الطريق
كيف أتخلص من هذه المشكلة
توصلت إلى فكرة تصميم نظارة
هذه النظارة سوف تنبه
السائق عندما يغمض عينه
وتصدر صوت إنذار يجعل السائق
يركز أكثر في القيادة
لم أحاول فقط ابتكار الإلكترونيات
مثل هذا الجهاز
بل أيضًا قمت بالبحث عن أشياء
في جسم الإنسان
مثلًا: كم مرة يرمش الإنسان في الدقيقة؟
وما هي سرعة رمشة العين
في أجزاء من الثانية؟
بعد البحث والبرمجة
توصلت إلى أنني أحتاج
الأشعة تحت الحمراء
لأنها هي التي تقيس المسافة
بين العين والنظارة
وتقيس سرعة رمشة العين في أجزاء من الثانية
فأخذت متحسس الـ IR
وهو متحسس الأشعة تحت الحمراء
هذا المتحسس به ثلاث مخارج
كما ترون أماكم في الشاشة
المخرج الأول نوصله
بالأردوينو -لوحة إلكترونية-
والمخرج الثاني نوصله بالأردوينو
أما الثالث فنوصله بالـ L3
هذا المتحسس يقوم بوظيفتين
الجزء الأبيض يقيس سرعة
رمشة العين في الثانية
أما الجزء الأسود فيقيس
المسافة بين العين والنظارة
فوضعت أيضًا جهازًا آخر
وهو الصفارة
هذا الجهاز أيضًا وصلته بالأردوينو
وفائدته أنه يصدر صوت التنبيه
عندما يغمض السائق عينه أثناء القيادة
لفترة أطول من 0.75 جزء من الثانية
سيصدر المتحسس
صوت التنبيه للصفارة
بحيث تعمل الصفارة
على إصدار صوت الإنذار
لدينا هذه النظارة
من منكم يود أن يجربها؟
تفضل
ارتدي النظارة وأبعدها قليلًا
الآن اترك عيناك مفتوحتان
الآن، عيناه مفتوحتان
لذلك لم يصدر صوت التنبيه
جرب الآن
أغمض عينيك
أغمضها لفترة طويلة
تصدر الآن صوت تنبيه
افتح الآن عينيك...
اختفى الصوت
الآن عندما يرمش
لن تصدر النظارة أي صوت تنبيه
ولكن عندما يغمض عينه
ستسمعون صوت التنبيه
مثل ما ترون
(تصفيق)
طبعًا تُبيّن لنا الإحصائيات
أن نسبة الوفيات التي تحدث بسبب الحوادث
نسبة كبيرة
حول العالم
ففكرت أنه هناك الكثير من الناس
يتعرضون لمثل هذه الحوادث وتكون
إما بسبب النوم أو عوامل أخرى
وهناك الكثير من الناس يرتدون النظارات
وآخرون لا يحبون ارتدائها أصًلا
فقلت لم لا أجعل الخطوة الآتية
أن يكون هذا الجهاز على عدسة النظارة
بحيث عندما يغمض السائق عينه
يصدر الجهاز صوت تنبيه تلقائيًا
ينبهه ويجعله يركز أكثر في القيادة
وفي الختام أود أن أقول لكم
أننا نحن جيل برامج التواصل الإجتماعي
وجيل ببجي
يفترض ألا تستهينون بنا
بل تفتخرون بنا
وعلى إدماننا ببرامج التواصل الإجتماعي
والألعاب الإلكترونية
(تصفيق)
ونحن طبعًا إذا استغللنا الفرصة
سوف نصنع من برامج التواصل الإجتماعي
الكثير من الأشياء وسنحل العديد من المشاكل
شكرًا لكم
(تصفيق)
♪  موسيقى ♪
♪ موسيقى ♪